bene tutti ragazzi venuti a questi
luoghi che sono fa vigilia ci siamo dati
con salvo in un'altra mappa che non è
valtur esattamente non è perduto si
chiama volta ci ha fatto venire le
viscere cielo ancora sul tavolo grazie
all esatto però oggi siamo sun caduta
libera praticamente sì quei programma di
gerry scotti quello dove cadde vinci
soldi no mi paghi tu lo salvano non è
quello no non abbiamo al contrario c'è
un contrario la sua parte zona ci sono
delle regole
vieni salvo aiutami ma faccio io spiega
che cosa dobbiamo fare da io non ho
capito vedi che questo è un tunnel one
bello lungo si è venduto nel mondo cioè
dell'acqua
si ok il tuo obiettivo è cadere
nell'acqua cadere nell'acqua ok vado ok
sono morto salgono che troll non è acqua
andrea acqua ero anch'io sono
sull'allora doveri in quello a sinistra
questo po di qua può fare
porca vacca è che lo faccia ma davvero
si trovata ci sono forte velocità
andiamo andiamo così devi cadere una
cosa all'altra fierissimi cadere ogni e
in teoria anche tunnel c'è un tipo
caratteristica di lei ha
un'ambientazione diversa next questo
numero due
quando disegna dell'élite si di
ritrovare dell'audio casa sono caduto
risultato non so non so bene ma è
bellissimo mi piace un sacco sti livelli
quindi tu cadi e mori e continui a
ripetere la cosa finché non la tua vita
non ha senso eccolo eccolo eccolo preso
rischiare ora vado non lo vedo io
lorenzo sly blog livello 3 ma come hai
fatto dove roseline block dov'era air in
fondo ma ti giuro non l'ho visto bene
anch'io finora sei stato bravo allora
prova a buttarti dvd cattiveria a
prendere velocità e andare a lato e
vedere se c'è dell'acqua non c'è allora
facciamo l'acqua non c'è un albero ho
preso un albero in faccia suri a posto
beh va bene a me non va bene però vabbè
ma no davvero luce acqua l'acqua e
moriamo e basta c'è l'altro slime ma non
lo vedo il blogger la difficoltà non è
cadere sopra e vederlo
essi non vedo cosa bisogna fare ho preso
il fuoco in faccia su ripepe sono forte
devi prendere
di atella non le vedo le ragnatela non
le vedo non le vedo adesso anche dove
sono io non le venderà il mezzo e mezzo
e tipo tipo di ok l'ho vista l'ho vista
l'evento le prendo portate vendone
avendo le prendo la prendo lo prenderò
presa volevo preso pesando l'ho presa ci
siamo ci siamo siamo
ciao questo tipo trani allora il diavolo
devi stare fermo non si muove
esatto se faremo burley ok e ora ce
l'abbiamo aspetto senza specie fammi
vedere qui dove che dovresti andare per
fare particola dopo e ci deve essere un
bottone a qualche parte un botto sul
blocco d'oro poi c'è un pesante quindi
potevano schiacciarlo anche in quello di
prima vabbè dai clicca bottone appello 4
o risi e intanto nasce dall'acqua
distanza si verifica a ok non glieli
beccarlo proprio all'angolino
qui il lavoro di precisi e mortacci mia
decisione e chi lo chiamavano il base
eletta io non ce l'ho fatta è che me fai
specchio di aspettami ma non ci sta il
bottone non ci sta tutto anche allora di
fare parkour da città darà il massimo
qualche modo sempre è forte non la
mettono te lo trovi anche nelle scatole
di cereali si trovi conservati j oggi
parkour e mai fare fatto di parlare
dentro l'acqua sopravvivi semmai qua si
è quindi è caduto però c'è dell'acqua là
in fondo con sé semi caduta o cacchio ho
un cuore poi compare così realtà sono
morto ok ok ce l'ho fatta linee del
previsto se ti aspetto famiglia indica
minore laico è proprio subito accanto al
vetro mi vedi si è chiusa dentro l'acqua
io sono dentro l'acqua viene addosso
ce l'ho fatta gare oltre che mi hai
fatto vedere l'acqua che sono un casinò
venezia essi mi chiamavano profeta
dovete chiuso è finito a era porta con
il profeta è click schiaccia il bottone
a posto
finalmente un livello difficile era
proprio quello che volevo grande grazie
gioco fuori dalla mappa chiedono
ammazzarvi il 36 per cento ne guarda qua
come gioventù secret aia mi sono dato il
giusto che lei non è largo ai a casa ma
vediamolo davvero complicato mamma mia
cosa ho visto a uno di quelli della lava
scialacquate se questo forza è no questo
non c'è però chi prati tutti lo giuro
non ho uno ce l'ha per forza questo
questo punto preciso e dipende da
roberto tutto tutto in teoria è quello
che ha in alto a destra quello henoko
l'orario proprio eccolo ce l'ho fatta ci
ho fatto
eccolo in alto a testa rotta adesso
cedeva dell'acqua sotto mamma mia quota
play e si gioca così ma l'emozione si
gioca così forti come le mie mani
giganti esatto esatto esatto è tolto la
l'unico del mondo che coglie la città
bello se si è imposto all'uomo ed ecco
questo non lo finiamo ragazzi spero che
questo video vi sia piaciuto però
aspetta quando non è impossibile se c'è
orca parte livello dell'acqua del fondo
noi vi dirò alle vicende che hai un
cuore solo e si e no niente qualunque
più scendere
credo della conca pistons acqua di vetro
quello no non trovare vetro quelle brave
e belle
si vede che si muove come va a essere
vero o no era vetro era vetro rotti
voglio ascoltare caro nero era vetro e
niente io mi sento un attimino bloccato
nel cast ufologo ok ok aspetta vedo il
vedo vedo aspettare dove l'islam mi
aspetta
no li avevo presi li hanno presi e
fattibile salvo e fattibili di capaccio
sisti e fatti insomma ci aspetta seguiva
guarda come
si veniva effetto equa bravo grande
hockey adesso quasi vedervelo slime se
non fosse perché ci è passata una nuvola
voglio andare a casa e ci riesce proprio
lui ma proprio quello degli sly bottone
clicca ce l'ho fatta
lo schiaccio maschiaccio ghiaccio ero
quasi arrivato anch'io quanto livello 8
in prossimo ho finalmente dato il
massimo da mino botta col a mano
peccato perché motivo ma dai che se non
c'era l'ultimo cosa ci avrei fatto e
vabbè se mia nonna in carriola roma 16
set aspetta che per donna avesse le
ruote crollava il dire ce la puoi fare
ciò puoi fare filati pilati pia timo
sentono sentono senza mai che c'ero
eccolo nome era vetralla m salvezza per
il vetro un'ora e mezza nella mente
nella mentre l'altro ma guarda io ci
credo sei bravissimo prima lo ha
guardato guarda guarda senti ti prego ti
schiaccia il tasto per favore aspetto
qui ma che mi aspetti
ok livello sono morto perché mi hai
teletrasportati in caduto impossible
fossimo mai salvo che vuol dire vai
salvo è niente mi sono buttato volo
spingerti ma questo mi sembra sarà la
morte questo mi sembra poco morte
questo non è molto dentro mercato perché
gli altri erano talmente facili come già
come ci vorrebbe un morte a l'ha presa
come l'hai presa come hai preso
io sono solo morto salvo schiacciato il
tasto per favore schiacciare devo
trovarlo allora io non so neanche come
hai fatto ad arrivare fin lì è
impossibile is easy non sono io anche
cosa easy ma guardando 10 bene
finalmente un livello di perché ha
finora era tutto talmente semplice da
quando ti dirò essendo così piccolo ci
sono tante cose che poi sbaglia
a immortalare roma dentro mortacci
questo impossibile tutto è nero cioè non
capisci dove è un buco e dov'è il nulla
palmor tacito come spinto è vero so che
mi aspetta
no guarda mi ero hanno beccato ma sono
rimbalzato a posto ce l'ho fatta e ce
l'ho fatta
no no no mamma mia che clip
non so come spiegarti fail non sono mai
spiegato voglio sapere se l'ho preso
sono ritornato su e quindi buttarmi
significa morire l'ho ripreso e se sono
morto perché sono no mortacci tua
ciò fattaccio fatto sapere se ho fatto
ciò fatta ci sono solo io so io so che
avrai pio signorini proprio lui
aspetto che è che mi arrivi in faccia
salvo vieni ma non c'è la parola va ai
proci prossima volta aspetta allora sono
qui e sono pronto sono carico se mio
personaggio che sono recati con la molla
che ha allagato dal bravo hai arrivato
morto come vale vale vale non fa male
salvo
dimmi perché a lo sai tu io ho
schiacciato il tasto e sono morto
era un paper lo giuro e sono due volte
che lo finisco e muoiono per home page
mi ha ucciso il tasto non so cosa è
successo ma non io ma il manico eccolo
contratto ho detto la parola pista nel
mondo volevo dire ma dio è però
dimenticato le dio illecito ma non io ma
ci sei e ti trasporta vittoria era
l'ultimo si dice queste situazioni
vado a morire i ragazzi ringrazio salvo
power per la capacità di
di direzionalità lei durante di vivere
durante questi salti con quello del
video sopra vi sia piaciuto iscritti al
canale e noi ci vediamo come sempre a un
prossimo darà di morte bella
[Musica]